all right so I finally saw Jojo rather
for some reason the universe are trying
to keep me from seeing Jojo rabbit
missed the screening actually I missed
the email for the screening for Jojo
rabbit I was like all right I can see it
in theaters hey it's in theaters great
I'll see it this Friday that was the
Friday they changed the movies out and
they lost Jojo rabbit so I couldn't see
it and it was like alright well I'll ask
two different critics to bring their
screen or screener is a DVD of the movie
that studios will send out to critics
it'll send that [ __ ] to me it's the
latest point I was like hey can you
bring it gonna cultivate multiple
options and can you bring it both won't
forget it both did so it's like fine
Universal right you don't want me to
watch Jojo rabbit it's okay I'll watch
it when there is a day in a week where I
need to feed the beast known as the
YouTube algorithm to keep my channel
from falling to obscurity well that day
is today that week is today so I finally
saw Jojo rabbit let's talk about wow
that intro is way too long
[Music]
so Jojo rabbits directed by Tycho YTD
there's a director of thor ragnarok he
also plays imaginary friend Hitler in
this movie I'm actually glad I don't
have to explain the movie Billy woo let
me explain was actually about when I
tell the premise to feel like this movie
got a lot of looks like that James
Franco meme when people heard about it
and all I heard about is about this
little Hitler Youth kid and his
imaginary friend Hitler and it's
accommodate with Nazis well what it's
actually about is this little Hitler
Youth kid yes but he finds his Jewish
girl hiding in his attic he starts
talking with her starts befriending her
and that makes his Dogma come face to
face with the reality he now knows and
that's how imaginary Hitler is in this
movie like Taika Waititi I thought he
did great as the imaginary Hitler in
this movement he's a caricature version
of Hitler because he's a part of the
ease of kid's mind he's the kid's
version of what he would see Hitler ad
because of all the [ __ ] and
propaganda these kids were shoveled so
it completely works in this world of
satire and like good satire this movie
is telling a story with a point and
that's what imaginary Hitler is in this
movie the Hitler that Taika Waititi
plays when this Hitler Youth kid who was
all gung ho for the Nazi ways comes face
to face with his Jewish girl starts
talking to her and at that point he has
to question the dogma that's been
shoveled to him imaginary Hitler is that
part of his brain trying to pull him
towards familiarity I thought it worked
brilliantly in this movie I thought
doesn't we did a really good job at
showing that people tend to want to go
back or they tend to let their brains
pull them towards familiarity even when
what's familiar isn't what's right
that's why this is a great coming-of-age
story does it address that bigotry is a
childlike mindset yes but also when you
come face-to-face with a situation that
directly conflicts or calls into
question what you've been taught go for
it lean into it ask those questions
maybe what you've been taught is
[ __ ] don't stubbornly stay locked in
the mental box they've locked you into
because well they said so following away
because you've been told to go that way
that's something kids do at a point you
got to question things because that's
what adults do so it's a bigger story
about humanity human nature human beings
and most importantly the movies
remarkably touching I didn't
that like I hadn't heard about that I'm
sure that's been addressed in reviews
but I don't listen to critics just told
I don't know I play my video games I
watch movies myself and I talk about
they had to have been addressed because
that's actually the meat of the movie
it's not just oh this kid and his
imaginary Hitler friend it's a really
touching story about a kid and his mama
his moms played by Scarlett Johansson I
thought she was great in the movie -
everyone's great in the movie I mean the
movies funny it made me laugh but it
never seemed to forget that it's dealing
with very serious subject matter and I
never found the movie offensive I feel
like there was a little bit of you know
controversy when it came out right I'm
not one of those people that comedy
offense I'm just not a couple jokes for
sure I was like oh you went there you
you did go there but those moments were
used to show the Nazis as the ridiculous
[ __ ] up faction it was but the movie
doesn't lock itself into just being
about Nazis it's not that simple
it's an applicable message when seen
with the Nazis in World War two it's an
applicable message today it will be an
applicable message one thousand years
from now if humanity lives that long I
wouldn't put my money on it but if we do
it kind of threw me off a couple times
when some of the comedy I mean that is
very 2009 teen comedy modern-day comedy
and lingo it's that's what I'm saying
which I get they're not trying to make a
period piece they're making satire
satire for a modern-day audience and I
love the fact that the movie addresses
the way to heal hate is through
conversation or at least the human
connection through conversation it
depresses me that no social media is not
that you cannot form that connection
during a screaming match or an argument
at two hundred and eighty characters at
a time all right Twitter rant over I
just I think it makes it worse
that's all in the end I was really
impressed with Jo Jo rabbit I think
calling it a comedy with a kid with an
imaginary friend who's Hitler that it
really undercuts the movie it doesn't
properly explain what the movie is it's
a comedy yes did I laugh yes was it
heartfelt yes it's about family human
beings the conflict between reality and
ideology where that line is where you
question things you have to stop
following because you've been told you
need to follow and you just got to think
for yourself it's baffling that it was
pulled off I'm not a lot of people could
pull this off the way Taika Waititi
pulled off Jo Jo rabbit I'd say it's
pretty genius let's say Jo Jo rabbits
definitely worth watching and definitely
worth buying on blu-ray funny would it
have been on my top 10 probably whatever
whatever stand by my top 10 top 11 now
all right so Jojo rabbit have you seen
it why did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here just anymore
[Music]